yeah welcome to this video and one
default plate and i played this guy
actually am before in in a game where
and did some warm up without doing
commander agee played exactly the Sun
this rather unambitious setup of course
you can do that it's not bad it's only
am a bit a bit boring ok let's do sorry
I'm I'm eating a little snack here hope
it's not too distracting alright is
actually doing something yeah quite
often the some somewhat crude approach
is dangerous the question is some how do
I react do I react and what the hell do
i play now ok let's just um prepare your
five this side cannot be too bad yeah I
form I know
yeah no idea maybe this is great what
what is doing I was playing quickly at
least you know what problem is if i play
on something like age six then yeah a
lot of squares will be weakened so I I
just continue him maybe he's playing
Bishop c4 now or some move like that I
was only playing f5 because I I sort of
expected this kind of stuff will see 383
man he played something similar in them
the game before so on yeah how to
continue him yeah actually I can do that
I mean it's a bit ugly but um the
structure takes to Queen takes I don't
really see what what why does sir is
doing in this position my pod structure
has weakened but it's still two bishops
and he's got the really ridiculous
looking night on age three maybe this is
exactly the piece that will kill me this
is quite usual actually you think I mind
this piece that he's got us just just
just so stupid and then you have a look
at tactic and this piece just just kills
you okay but then after the capture here
on there's actually Queen takes g2 as a
possibility maybe not instantly but it's
in the position
and this really Kim thought a form f4
and stuff like that okay let's first get
the King out of this I actually can
cancel long I mean no problem so what
now and I was thinking about F form a
foursome the real opener yam that this
must be must be right really let's open
up the position there's Bishop g4 as a
possibility and also other ideas if he
takes on fyf takes our d 4 so the
bishops really open up and if he goes d
5 then there's the idea Bishop g4 and
the Queen has no square it can go to e4
but then I have ideas with detecting the
exchange or maybe here's something
better even so I'm not quite clear
what's best against e5 but let's let's
first see what he is what he's playing
if he takes on e5 um that's more than 11
IDM okay here thought just takes on d4
as a simple solution I get the pawn back
and the long diagonal opens up there's
also Bishop g4 but if I would have done
that before then there's Queen to g3 NM
in the pin so don't want that but now I
can just take with the night right then
threatening made actually on on c2 and
maybe not before maybe night before was
an idea of course this is this is all
right for me not bad at all but maybe
him I should have
thought a bit longer okay this is not
bad i'm threatening not be three with
mate and 92 also so just this be to pawn
is under tech and yeah this is one way
to to covered so um now let's see I
think this certainly I can just take the
Queen am an idiotic today I completely
forgot that i did i've been taking the
Queen sorry I can just take it of course
I was only thinking about the maid
threat and I completely ignored that the
queen is saying i think it was hanging
before right Bishop d3 about he was
attacking my queen it was attacking my
queen yeah yeah 94 I mean I completely
ignored that this is threatening the
Queen this is funny and then he played
Bishop e3 and well I didn't really see
that the queen is hanging I mean it was
just a coincidence if I take now him he
takes here and it's not so much
happening but of course yeah Queen have
six wins but I didn't really I
absolutely didn't see that the queen is
saying and this means it's over because
this is simply not be 30 e2 and made on
be too so it's a it's just just made now
are winning the Queen act completely
completely overlooked that it is saying
and at this I was thinking well but
should be five or not be five because
queen 88 made and at this moment when I
was thinking about b5 and queen aah
checkmate I noticed wait this queen is
saying oh man okay but fun fun game I
hope you enjoyed it
you